tus amigos y tú están haciendo tarjetas
para asignar asientos para la cena cada
uno de ustedes recibe una tira de papel
en blanco idéntica cada uno de ustedes
divide su tiren un número diferente de
partes y luego pintan algunas de estas
partes en azul cuál de las tiras de tus
amigos tiene la misma porción de color
azul que la tuya
pensemos me tira del papel está dividida
en seis partes iguales esta es la mía la
imagen de abajo muestra lo que he
pintado de azul así es que me tira
tendrá 1 2 3 4 5 6 partes iguales
y he dibujado cuatro de ellas en azul
así es que tengo cuatro de seis ahora
analizaremos las tiras de maika de joel
y de holden maika o mika dividió sutil
en tres partes iguales así es que
pongamos que tiene tres partes iguales
de las cuales ha pintado 2
de qué manera puedo lograr convertir
estos dos tercios a cuatro sextos serán
una fracción equivalente voy a ponerlo
de otro color para que sea mucho más
sencillo
que podamos hacer esta comparación vamos
a pintar
las dos partes de maicao
tiene dos pintadas de tres partes
iguales cómo puedo saber si cuatro
sextos y dos tercios son equivalentes la
manera en la que podemos hacer es
pensando puedo multiplicar o dividir
estos cuatro sextos por el mismo número
tanto el numerador como el denominador
para que el producto o resultado sea dos
tercios en este caso si el cuatro sextos
lo divido entre dos tendré el numerador
entre 24 entre 2 es igual a 2 y el
numerador también lo dividiré entre 2
para que mantengamos el valor de la
fracción 6 entre 2 es igual a 3
y tenemos exactamente los dos tercios
que tienen mike a otra manera en la que
podemos pensarlo es desde estos dos
tercios
si yo multiplico tanto el numerador como
el denominador por 2 tendré 2 por 2 es
igual a 4 y 3 por 2 será igual
y tenemos la misma fracción que
originalmente he puesto yo esto lo
hicimos de manera numérica si lo hacemos
de manera gráfica también podemos ver lo
siguiente si nosotros tenemos
seis partes iguales y las agrupamos de
dos en dos tendremos uno
tres bloques de los cuales dos estarán
pintados de azul uno
de esta manera tenemos los mismos dos
tercios que hay acá o al revés que tal
que dividimos los tercios de maika entre
y entonces tendremos 12
56 bloques totales de los cuales tendrá
cuatro pintados de morado
es una forma más en la que podemos
comprobar que estas dos fracciones son
equivalentes vamos a analizar la
situación con joel y con holden para
saber si esto también aplica con ellos
joel tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 partes iguales
de las cuales 4 están pintadas de azul
las voy a pintar en anaranjado para que
sea más evidente del cambio y sea más
sencillo poder hacer la diferencia
tenemos entonces estas cuatro de siete
partes como pudiéramos llegar a cuatro
sextos a partir de cuatro séptimos
realmente el cuatro pudiera pudiera
hacernos pensar que sería equivalente
sin embargo no encuentro de manera obvia
en ningún número en el que podamos
multiplicar o dividir
tanto el numerador como el denominador
de esta fracción para que nos dé como
resultado producto 4 sextos joel queda
descartado y finalmente holden tiene 5
partes iguales 1 2 3 4 5
de las cuales ha pintado tres los voy a
poner en verde uno dos tres y podemos
hablar que tiene tres quintos hay alguna
manera en la que estos tres quintos se
puedan convertir en cuatro sextos no hay
ningún número por el que pueda
multiplicar tanto a numerador y
denominador para que nos dé cuatro
sextos así es que holden queda también
descartado con eso tenemos la respuesta
correcta mica o maika tiene la misma
porción de color pintada que nosotros